Now what we want to do is extract the
url. So we found this position, that's going to be
the value of start_link. Now our goal is to extract
this url. And the url starts from the first double
quote that we find after start link, and it
ends with the second double quote. So for the last
quiz of this unit, your goal is to write all
the code we need to end up finding that url.
So this is going to be the hardest quiz that we've had so far. It's going to
involve you thinking about variables, thinking how
to use find in different ways. And write
several lines of code yourself. Think carefully
about how to do this. But I think
if you understand what we've covered so far, you'll be able to do this yourself.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So to be specific, here's the quiz, your goal is
to write Python code that assigns to the variable url.
These are all lowercase letters, a string that is the
value of the first URL found on the page, in
a link tag. So you should assume that we have
the variable page that's already initialized to the contents of
the page. And in your browser this will be initialized
to the contents of an example page. From the previous
quiz we also have the value of start-link already
worked out. It said start-link is the result of calling
find on page, passing in the string, a href
equals. And your goal is to finish this code, so
at the end of this code, the value of url is the first link on the page. And if
you print the value of url, and you've done
all the code correctly for the example that we provided,
you should get the result http://udacity.com,
which is the url that finds the Udacity webpage. So this is pretty tough quiz.
There's a lot of steps. Think about it carefully. So it uses almost everything
that you've seen in the unit today. You'll
have to think about how to use the find
method, possibly passing in numbers as well as strings,
as well as variables to keep track of things.
To find the result, you'll also need to think about how to
use the string indexing operators to select a sub-sequence of a string.